they call it the
the kung fu the virus the the china
virus
like the way they said it and the way
the media the news was spinning it was
disrespectful
right you know because of you know
whatever
whatever um standings that
america has with china right whatever
that is you know at the end of the day
i'm chinese but i'm american
i was born and raised here like i don't
know like i go to china they're not
going to treat me like i'm chinese
what i'm saying because i'm american you
know so
i don't know what the [ __ ] is going i
don't know what's going on out there i
don't know right i mean but
because how they they they
they spin it in the media it makes it
look like all right oh well well it's
not just
the people if not it's not just the
government china
it's the chinese people right and in
america
we don't know anybody besides we don't
know any other asian
um ethnicities besides chinese right
everybody's chinese to a lot of people
you know
so a lot of people right so when you
when you do that but
but everybody's not chinese asia is made
up of 48 different countries
there's malaysians there's different
languages
it's not like puerto ricans and mexicans
they speak different versions of spanish
but it's still spanish you're still
rooted in spanish yeah
we speak totally different [ __ ] like we
don't like 100
the culture is different everything is
different the food is different
it's a whole different world you know
what i'm saying so now
when somebody like trump comes out and
says yo
the china virus the kung fu virus right
and then put it in a disrespectful
spin right now the media spins it
and then yeah sure it's like you know
everybody that's doing these things and
that's partaking in these things
aren't like trump supporters but it's
not just trump it's the whole media
like spinning this this this you know
this [ __ ] so now people
what we're seeing is a byproduct of that
you know what i'm saying like people
you know taking yeah let's move this
ashtray people
subscribing to that [ __ ] yeah and then
you gotta understand
the the the the coronavirus shut the
world down for a whole year
for sure we never seen that before and
for china probably i mean well china has
probably handled it the most swiftly
right but in america
right in america our ship was shut down
for a whole year
right and that that [ __ ] up a lot of
things for people you know what i'm
saying
it made people stay in the house for
months
uh uh it messed up people's jobs
businesses you know what i'm saying
people
people who needed me like mental like
like you know any type of care or [ __ ]
like that they didn't get that
you know what i mean hospitals are
closing they're letting people go
police is pulling back you know all of
this is happening right
and with you know they need people need
somebody to blame
you know what i'm saying people need
somebody to blame like you know i'm
frustrated like all of this is happening
but you know
um and then so now when the media says
oh
it's the chinese virus it's the kung fu
virus yeah i'm saying
then people gonna respond to that you
know what i mean people that has
mental disabilities people that has like
just you know that just
that that's just messed up in their head
or people that's just frustrated that's
bored that just want to do some stupid
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying they gonna go
and do this stupid [ __ ] and that's
what's happening right now you know
i feel like you know this is just you
know this
is this is this is the byproduct of that